un flujo de heridos es transportado
fuera de la base militar de labor y
cerca del bid y a menos de 25 km de
polonia a un estado miembro de la unión
europea y la otan el parlamento
ucraniano compartió esta foto de las
secuelas de un ataque nocturno a la base
por parte de aviones rusos desde el mar
negro
según la información preliminar los
aviones despegaron en sarátov en rusia y
cometieron un ataque sin entrar en
territorio de ucrania según la
información que eliminar se dispararon
más de 30 cohetes
en estas imágenes el ejército ucraniano
se entrena en la base de jagori
instruido por asesores del ejército
estadounidense es uno de los mayores
complejos militares de ucrania y fue un
centro de ejercicios conjuntos otan
ucrania según los medios de comunicación
y ucranianos todos los instructores
extranjeros abandonaron el campo de
entrenamiento a mediados de febrero y la
otan confirmó que ningún miembro de su
personal estaba allí durante este ataque
hasta ahora a la ciudad de lviv y la
región circundante se habían librado del
asalto ruso es un punto de tránsito
clave para las armas que llegan a
ucrania y para los civiles que intentan
desesperadamente huir de los combates
el alcalde de iván los franquistas
también en el western de ucrania dice
que los misiles han alcanzado al
aeropuerto local y se está pidiendo a
los residentes de la ciudad que busquen
de refugio estos ataques sugieren que
moscú está ampliando sus objetivos
después de advertir que atacaría los
envíos de armas que se dirigen al país